an oiled up interview with a childhood
Crush stowing away in a stranger's trunk
and wrestling a judo champion at a fancy
party over the years the Shameless
Impractical Jokers have come up with
some truly Unforgettable gags for MERS
punishment for losing in poor taste buds
he got what initially seems like a
pretty enjoyable task being a culinary
expert and critic tasting and draining
food in front of a class however the
guys soon let him in on the twist his
mouth is going to be injected with as
much novocaine as is clinically allowed
just before going on stage meaning he
won't be able to taste anything or speak
properly as soon as the dentist injects
the novocaine its effect is noticeable
on myrrh most people get spaghetti and
meatballs in a bolognese sauce most
people get the spaghetti meatballs and
bolognese sauce
struggles to pronounce most words
including those with the letters b p s
and F taking advantage of this the guys
make him repeat alliterated sentences
using those letters constantly braised V
is brilliant
raised raised Leaf is
soon myrrh has to start eating and
drinking the food which becomes quite
the ordeal since he can't feel anything
that his mouth is doing the combination
of Mer's hilarious struggles with
completing sentences along with the
great audience reaction make import
taste buds one of myrrh's top pranks of
all time the guys in Impractical Jokers
kick off season 2 with a bang with the
episode elephant in the room the first
challenge is the holy molar challenge
which sees the guys pretending to be
dentists and interacting with patients
of course having to do whatever they are
told for example Q informs his patience
he has an embarrassing story about
sexually transmitted infections and
Atlantic City before using the suction
wand on his face tell them that's not
your worst story about crabs crab cake
so that's not my worst story involving
crabs in Atlantic City if you know what
I mean Sal's up next and he has to
practically invert his patient on the
dental chair before running out of the
room and leaving him hanging upside down
for several minutes keeping the chair
moving the whole time buddy don't stop
Joe starts telling his patient about the
various dental tools at his disposal
including shoehorns and dubiously named
pliers in the industry we call this the
bilateral hammering
the best performance is from mer who
simply spins and Twirls around the room
on the wheelchair for the strip high
five prank Murr and Joe have to deal
with an ultra rare double punishment
when both of them tie for last after
three challenges the two have to stand
in the middle of Union Square and play a
game of strip high five the idea is that
each of them has to try and get
strangers to high-five them for every
stranger who refuses to high-five them
they have to remove an article of
clothing both of the guys have some
success at first as most people are
pretty friendly as soon as they start
losing more clothes people are more
reluctant to have anything to do with
them sir high five
[Music]
pretty soon the guys attract a crowd of
onlookers and they both get down to
their underwear Joe is successful in
getting a high five in his underwear but
Myrrh is not so lucky please give me a
high five please
and he ends up getting his underwear
pulled down by Joe in the middle of the
street Joe then grabs the rest of MERS
clothes and dashes off leaving him
standing there barely able to cover
himself looking deeply deeply ashamed it
was as Q called it the most public of
humiliations season one of Impractical
Jokers has some of the series best
moments and the that looks delicious
prank from the episode titled out of TP
is no exception for this challenge the
guys find themselves at a buffet
restaurant unfortunately for them they
aren't allowed to purchase any of the
food
instead they have to grab food from the
plates of unsuspecting diners and
whoever ends with the least amount of
food on their plate loses Pew goes first
but he almost immediately forfeits after
no one gives him the time of day hi how
are you
you seem very nice I'm not okay
Murr gets caught instantly trying to
grab some corn and another guy notices
him grabbing a wing though he doesn't
say anything he steals another woman's
okra and his plate ends up weighing a
respectable one pound four ounces at the
end Sal immediately starts grabbing food
from patrons left and right but he only
comes up with one pound total the amount
of dirty looks that are getting thrown
you away is Mayhem going on out here
this complete me
Joe is the final contestant and he
starts scatting while grabbing food from
a few female patrons one of them alerts
her husband who decides to test Joe out
and see if he tries it with him when Joe
does the guy smacks his macaroni spoon
away from him Joe ends up following him
to the table and grabs some fried
chicken after a brief Tong fight but his
plate still weighs under a pound and he
loses along with Q the best Impractical
Jokers punishments are brutally public
and the one from below the belt is an
all-time classic Murr is the loser of
the episode so he has to endure the
punishment his task is to deliver a
PowerPoint lecture on the science behind
climate change which Murr claims he can
do in his sleep however while Myrrh is
giving the speech the guys will have
access to his lower body via a hollow
table he is standing in front of the
audience can't see the guys under the
table and they immediately start making
Mer's presentation as difficult as
possible Sal Begins by waxing one of
Mer's legs while he's speaking making
merg Grimace and squirm still allows
next up is Q who sprays Mer's pants with
a water bottle to make it look like he
wet himself he then has to step on a
mousetrap and walk around wearing
high-heeled shoes confusing the audience
immensely but that wasn't even the most
embarrassing part of the prank
what
hi
[Music]
Roz is when Joe turns MERS slacks into
shorts again making him parade around in
front of a bewildered and amused
audience as punishment for losing the
junk in the trunk challenges Sal had one
of his most high energy moments on the
show The Gag is that the guys are at a
local car rental agency and Sal has to
hide in the trunk of one of the vehicles
he's supposed to ride along in the trunk
until the person needs to open it at
which point they'll see him and be
shocked the prank gets off to a
seemingly Rocky start when the renters
take the car on a much longer trip than
expected Sal rattles around in the trunk
while the woman drives around smacking
his head several times
oh
speedwell's going up oh God no no
eventually the car stops and a woman
gets out and opens the trunk
finally when it seems like the woman is
truly upset Joe reveals the truth it's
actually his friend Melissa who knew
about Sal in the trunk the whole time
her getting upset was all an act and Sal
bought it hook line and sinker
one of the funniest recurring pranks on
Impractical Jokers is the did I deserve
that challenge for these challenges the
guys are working as cashiers behind a
store counter when an irate customer
barges in and throws water at their
faces while they are in the middle of a
transaction the guys then have to sell
whatever excuse they are told to get the
customer to say they did not deserve it
what did we do wrong we're gonna find
out and no matter how bad it is we've
got to defend it the first time the guys
did the challenge was during the episode
the blunder years and it was one of the
funniest of the series Joe and Sal
successfully get a no from their
customers I put like thousands of
mosquitoes in his house and I thought
he'd get the hint I mean do you think I
deserve that no now but Murr doesn't
have the same luck though he does win
100 in a side bet from Joe after
caressing the chest hair of a customer
the final participant is q but that's
when the entire prank goes awry and ends
up creating one of the best Impractical
Jokers moments of all time
[Music]
[Applause]
the actor quickly realizes his mistake
but maintains there's nothing he can do
now luckily the aggrieved party is a
good sport about the whole thing and is
able to laugh it off you know the
punishment is going to be good and
Impractical Jokers when it covers almost
half the episode and MERS Judo bout
during a poolside cocktail party in the
episode The Party Crasher is one of
these rare few for this punishment Murr
has to crash a cocktail party and start
a wrestling match with two-time U.S
Olympic gold medalist Judo Champion
Kayla Harrison myrrh already looks
incredibly conspicuous wearing a wig
made from Q's hair and his constant
flailing at Kayla quickly gets the
attention of all the party guests and
he's only allowed to say one thing about
the situation I know her from college
after she rips off his toupee during an
ill-fated takedown attempt he has to put
it back on and continue wearing it
looking completely disheveled at one
point Kayla throws myrrh through a table
and he just tries to play it off as best
he can oh my God
for the finale Kayla launches myrrh over
her head into the pool after his final
failed attack the guests clap and cheer
for Kayla who walks back and enjoys the
rest of the party seeing Murr get
manhandled by an Olympic gold medalist
was a highlight of the season and one of
the best celebrity cameos of the entire
series the episode Blind Justice
features one of Sal's best all-time
punishments his task is to act as a
hardened convict and give a Scared
Straight speech to a room full of
teenagers he thinks the only catch is
that he has to wear a pair of sunglasses
that 100 obscure his View and use a few
props however the guys reveal to the
audience the true deviousness of the
punishment he is in fact not speaking to
a crowd of teenagers shut up
laughs
I don't want to hear anybody he lectures
them about not disappointing their
parents and warns them about spending
the next 50 years of their life in
prison the audience starts laughing at
the ridiculous speech Sal hears this but
doesn't fully understand which just
makes him yell more tight boy
[Music]
eventually he puts two and two together
the Soul not in teens taking glasses off
[Music]
and for the grand finale Sal shows them
his Jaden Smith tattoo which makes them
all break out in hysterics it's no
secret to fans of the show that myrrh
had a massive childhood crush on Danica
McKellar an actress from one of his
favorite childhood shows The Wonder
Years for his punishment in the blunder
years episode myrrh has to interview
McKellar in a hotel conference room
while that sounds pretty desirable Murr
has to do so while completely oiled up
and wearing a speedo the guys tell him
he's going to enter a bodybuilding
contest which gives them covered to
douse him with oil and put him in a
speedo but it was all just a ruse behind
the door is going to be a celebrity that
is Murray's childhood crime during the
interview MERS told what to say Truth or
Dare I'll go first truth I used to kiss
a poster review when I was younger and
she is told to act as harshly as
possible with myrrh and she delivers in
Spades finish this equation
me plus u equals
really awkward
after thoroughly embarrassing himself by
trying to do squats and Flex for her Mer
is mercifully allowed to leave the room
in McKellar alone as soon as she walks
out she bursts out laughing but Myrrh is
probably scarred for life the pranks
where the guys participate in panels are
definite Staples on Impractical Jokers
one of Q's most hilarious was from
Brother of The Sisterhood Q has to sit
in on a panel of experts talking about
feminism posing as the author of a Blog
titled brother of The Sisterhood and of
course he must disagree with everything
the panelists say I think Michelle Obama
is a fantastic right that she wouldn't
be in the white house if her husband
having gotten her there the host is in
on the joke but no one else is least of
all the audience members first Q has to
explain the difference between men's
jobs and women's jobs hey man I'm all
for you know women's rights I mean who
isn't but I also want my car to run well
then he is forced to defend a quote from
his fictional blog where he claimed that
women becoming mothers turn emotionally
unstable and irrational these ladies
have gone through a lot
you know
after several minutes of excruciatingly
uncomfortable and cringe-worthy banter Q
has to give his closing remarks and they
consist solely of him telling the almost
exclusively female audience that he
finds it amazing they can go all day
without playing with their breasts it is
without a doubt one of Q's most
embarrassing and awkward punishments in
the series The Coupe might be the best
known and longest lasting prank in
Impractical Jokers history merge the
loser in this episode and his punishment
is that he has to wear a wig it doesn't
sound too bad Until you realize whose
hair he's wearing cues the guys have q
cut off his shoulder-length hair and
make it into a wig for Murray
going on
the wig doesn't look half bad at first
but doesn't suit Mur at all to make
matters worse Murr has to get his
passport picture taken with the wig this
is to contrast with Mer's driver's
license which features him with a shaved
head and shaved eyebrows from an earlier
punishment Murr claims the hair smells
like whiskey and pot
unfortunately from her he can't just
take off the wig after a day he has to
keep it on for the remainder of the
Season there are several more episodes
in season 6 after the coupe and Mer's
hair just gets worse and worse as time
goes on the fact that it keeps going
throughout the season makes it by far
the best Impractical Jokers prank in the
series it's almost like multiple
punishments in one as every episode with
him wearing it is like an extra prank
[Music]